[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I saw her today at the reception a glass
of wine and I am I knew she was gonna
meet her connection out of feet was a
Footloose man you know you can't always
get what you want can't always get what
you want can't always get what you want
[Music]
but if you try sometimes
you'll find
and you get what you need Oh baby you
get what you need getting my fair share
of abused singing we're gonna vent our
frustration if we don't gonna blow a
50-amp use what I say
[Music]
you can always get what you want can
always get what you want if you tried
sometimes
Oh
get what
[Music]
chelsey trust
gives our description field
[Music]
understanding it mr. Jim
[Music]
favorite flavor
to mr. Jimmy always get what you want
what you want
what you are
you're fine
[Music]
plus all nerdy at the reception in a
blast world bleeding my hair she's
practiced at the heart of deception
ah
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes
[Music]
get what you need
[Music]
people think that a book consists only
of a text and that you can digitize that
text and then you need the physical
object but a book is a whole series of
texts there's a text in the annotations
in the margin there's a text in
ownership and therefore potentially the
readership of the book there's a text
and how the books put together and how
it's made the materials it's made out of
they speak to the time and place that
the person who read it lived one of the
great parts of aass collection is the
Mather family library and each
successive generation this family added
to this library and they added to the
annotations in the margins but one of my
favorite quotes of all these annotations
is an annotation that Cotton Mather made
in the book there was a book attacking
him and attacking his family and he
wrote in the margin the quote from the
Bible if my enemy has written the book I
will take it and bind it unto myself as
a crown of thorns unto me
in my experience bill usually talks
longer than that so I was expecting a
little more than just that
good afternoon as it's a mixed pleasure
to see you all here today we're gathered
here of course this afternoon thanks to
the family of bill Reese and the by
Nikki library to pay tribute to a
scholar and a friend our own beloved
bill Thank You Dorothy Bill's wife bar
bill sister Terry bless track of where
you are bills business partner as well
as all the staff of the Reese company a
host of Bill's closest friends and the
by Nicki for making this occasion
possible for us and thank you all of you
for taking the time to come here today
to honor and revisit how much you care
about Bill Reese in gathering today to
remember bill we are processing our
grief all the internal thoughts and
feelings we've experienced and will
continue to experience because of Bill's
death and as we talk about and think
about bill we will be pulling these
feelings from deep inside ourselves out
into the community into this room to
experience mourning grief is what you
think and feel inside
mourning is when you express that grief
outside of yourself mourning is kind of
grief inside out
and mourning is how we move towards
healing this is hard but necessary work
after all we're still alive we can't
heal without mourning or expressing our
grief outwardly I think all of you
already know this and unfortunately have
probably experienced at close hand in
your lives so we're here today to
celebrate built and our love for him
what an irony of life that love would be
the cause of our grief but grief is the
price we pay for that love they go
together our feelings of love for
someone who is now dead are no different
from when that person was alive that
love connection continues to exist in
fact it never goes away it is the stuff
our universe is made of that's what
makes grief so hard but when we open to
the pain of our loss when we acknowledge
its depth and are willing to embrace it
and discuss it openly we honor it and
the person who is the subject of it that
doesn't mean that our grief will go away
I doubt that any of us will ever forget
Bill Reese or stop missing him but in
giving ourselves permission to remember
and mourn him we can legitimize our
grief and get some comfort and joy
out of hearing each other's experiences
with bill now I know because I am Bill's
cousin that most of the really good
stories are not gonna be from this
podium but I'm kind of hoping I'll hear
a few of them in the hallways of the by
Nicki later today we may even today
learn something new about Bill who had
so many different parts to his life and
who remained to the very end such a
modest and private public person that
very few people could say they really
knew all of bill Reese in short we can
keep bill alive by sharing our memories
of him and through our remembrances we
can create meaning out of the horror of
his death we can give our feelings and
Bill's life a greater context memory
after all is an essential part of our
humanity it's a building block of our
intelligence our self-awareness and our
ability to grow and improve
we remember the dead particularly when
their lives have proved a worthy example
when their acts or words have touched
our hearts I don't think this is a new
concept for a room full of historians
and book dealers granted our memories
tend to forget the bad parts and magnify
the good parts and that may be just part
of God's grace in the whole mourning
process but our memories touch us so
deeply because they are really a
reliving a rien Singh
of our feelings for this person for Bill
and what he meant to us we remember the
dead whom we love as our way of not
losing them entirely of keeping them
within the community they interacted
with when they were alive and this
formal way of remembering helps us shift
our relationship from physical presence
to one of deep memory so that healing
can begin and our loss and the value of
Bill's life can be put into a larger and
more accessible setting again I am
preaching to the choir I know having
this memorial today is a way of showing
our gratitude for knowing and
experiencing bill and of saying to
ourselves that we value those traits and
qualities that we admired in Bill when
he was alive we hold these
distinguishing characteristics up to
keep them alive within us in the hopes
that they'll continue to add value and
meaning to our lives maybe we even hope
a little bit that these qualities will
rub off on us because we notice them and
valued them in someone else again I'm
preaching to the choir I know it would
be an understatement to say that Bill's
life amounted to something you all
wouldn't be here if he wasn't who he was
and what he had accomplished hadn't
meant something really important to you
if you didn't love him in some way that
you wanted to honor and make note of
we all have our personal bills stories
he touched every one of us in some very
special meaningful ways many of you will
share your bill stories today from the
podium and I thank you deeply for doing
so
I also encourage all of you to continue
to share bill bill stories throughout
the afternoon and evening and from now
on at any time whenever you who knew him
gather together I would like to briefly
share some of my thoughts about my
cousin the brother I always wish that I
had bill was in the truest sense of the
phrase a gentleman and a scholar he was
also a family man an athlete an
adventurer a natural educator an ardent
lover of good books good wine good food
this is good women and hard work he
lived life with such gusto and such an
unparalleled curiosity just about
everything fascinated bill on some level
and just about everyone interested him
bill had a generosity of spirit and
resources that spanned his prodigious
knowledge and regularly rained down on
his many worldwide friendships he was as
one close longtime friend said recently
usually the smartest guy in the room yet
he remained largely unaffected by his
brain power and his uncanny ability to
synthesize even the most disparate and
difficult range of material
into some cogent hole always there was
this great dry sense of humor that
matched his boundless energy and his
willingness to take on insurmountable
tasks with the greatest of a lone and
effectiveness his knowledge as we all
know was both wide and deep his
goofiness both entertaining and
endearing there isn't a game that bill
didn't master or a sport that he wasn't
exceptionally good at and I'm pretty
sure there wasn't a subject he didn't at
some point have a book on I have been
like so many of us here today
constantly enriched and enlarged by
knowing my cousin Bill at the risk of
overly lionizing him my cousin always
seemed to do the right thing at the
right time in the right way for the
right reasons we all know that that
combination is rare indeed he
exemplified for me that to the highest
standard of integrity and service within
our family within the larger group of
friends that we shared and within what I
know of his profession he gave so
generously of himself and of his ideas
and his material assets that we will
never know the full impact of his life
or how many people he truly touched in
his modesty of course bill didn't want
us to know that and so we don't
I am so glad that bill knew great love
with Dorothy and that he had a rewarding
business with Terry and a staff that he
adored appreciated and counted on at the
Reece company I'm so glad he had his
sisters Kathy who's now deceased and
Barr who is very much alive and that she
produced three magnificent children who
were and still are the Apple a bill and
Dorothy's lives as well as all of ours
and it's a great delight to me to have
seen Tessa a few weeks ago I'm sorry to
have seen Sarah a few weeks ago and
realized that her little baby is named
William there is still a William around
in the world to be where next generation
and I'm glad that bill had the farm as
an anchor as a source of strength as
well as a creative canvas in these later
years and always as one of the many
places where he and Dorothy and their
tribe and there is a tribe could gather
and enjoy life together
Bill's life wasn't anywhere near long
enough for all of us who loved him there
was much more that he could have and
would have done there are so many more
people he would have touched if he had
had the time but the important thing to
me is that even though this was a life
cut short it was a life fully lived it
was a life that mattered and Bill made
sure it was a life we would all remember
with a smile and some good stories
thank you
Thank You Posie and thank you all for
coming today to honor Bill's life I'd
like to note before I begin that though
they could not be here today
my sister's Sarah and Tessa helped me
greatly in the writing of this eulogy
mm-hmm when I was younger I often
enjoyed eating breakfast on study
mornings with my family at a small
restaurant called Uncle Bill's pancake
house as the name suggests they were
widely known for their pancakes
I however enjoyed eating there not
because of their short stacks but
because I had an Uncle Bill it was in
large part due to this diner that I grew
up knowing Bill as Uncle Bill
the prefix to his name slowly in my mind
became an honorific title as I began to
understand just how impressive he was I
had a famous uncle and it somehow seemed
especially cool that his fame was
limited to the largely unknown world of
antiquarian book dealing I'm glad that
got a laugh in this crowd accounts of
his brilliance were a source of pride
for our entire family my aberrant my
admiration for Bill developed through
such stories it was not until my late
teens that I questioned my perception of
our relationship the prompt for review
came directly from him as he asked my
sister Sarah why of all eras ankhila
relations he was the only one we
continually named as uncle what was for
me something that needed no explanation
was for him an idiosyncrasy that set him
apart from our other family in this he
wasn't wrong however it was not only his
title that set him apart with reverence
came intimidation and an inability on my
end too openly converse when I began to
call him solely by his name our
interactions began to flow more freely I
began to actually experience and
race his wit intelligence generosity
compassion characteristics which I had
previously only been able to observe and
admire this change in the way I engaged
with Bill was for me a certain awakening
to the power of words the term uncle had
so strongly defined my ability to relate
with another person Bill through his
extensive reading deeply understood
language not only as a mechanism by
which information is communicated but
also as a way for individuals to express
and convey the wide range of emotions
intrinsic to the human condition
it was his ability to translate written
word into the underlying sentiment that
enabled him to so fully understand
history not only as discrete events but
as continuous narratives of personal and
collective experiences through his
baritone voice he brought his
understanding of the past into the
present by way of vivid storytelling he
was generous with the knowledge and
wisdom he acquired sharing carefully
considered advice and guidance to those
who sought it though there were many
instances when he provided me with
counsel it was not any particular moment
of mentorship that endeared me to him
rather it was the model of magnanimity
and love that he embodied the power of
story also impacted my sister's
relationship with Bill Tessa rights
being anis to Bill has been a choice on
both ends he embracing uncle and me
embracing niece it was a unique and
special bond and one I feel the absence
of deeply and dearly bill had his unique
ways of uncle and one of them was to
give books
when I was younger I remember being
baffled by some of the books he would
gift me often a reach beyond where I
thought I was at the time and yet
remarkably right in line with where I
found myself to be a little while later
one of the first books I can remember
him giving me was Aesop's fables this
book had a profound impact on me as it
taught me how wisdom can live within
stories and how our moral compass is
built up of the lessons and guiding
figures we encounter not only in the
flesh but in books as well the fable of
the wind and the Sun found in your
leaflet is one that tessa feels captures
a certain quality of bills for my part
in recent years the farm on which bill
grew up and where I have been living was
a central part of my interactions with
him conversations had while walking the
property helped me to develop my
understanding of land conservation and
stewardship he would often when speaking
of land management decisions employ a
quote by Thomas Jefferson the earth
belongs to the living Jefferson wrote in
a letter to James Madison in his letter
Jefferson explores what obligations one
generation has to the next on this topic
he goes further in saying that by the
law of nature one generation is to
another as one independent nation to
another when Bill evoked this quote he
wasn't saying that obligations of the
dead should be forgotten rather that it
is the responsibility of the living to
incorporate the teachings of their
forebears
into their decision-making and in so
doing bridge the gap between generations
I am now an uncle my nephew William
Sarah's son is not yet two years old the
fact that he too is named William is to
me impactful and not coincidental as it
highlights the cyclic nature of family
bonds as I begin to define my
relationship with my nephew I will
undoubtedly turn to builds model for
guidance bill was a central figure in my
own coming of age he enabled me to find
my voice and with occasional subtle
coercion to make decisions independently
he always treated me as an equal bill
has touched the world in many ways one
perhaps lesser-known or more private way
has been through the maintenance of a
strong sense of family as he taught me
the earth belongs to the living I will
do my best to continue his legacy not
least through my own role as uncle thank
you
good afternoon I'm Randy Katz and Bill
and I were students here in the mid 70s
before I talked about celebrating these
40 plus years of knowing Bill I want to
share a little historical perspective of
the the building that were in the
esteemed Yale Law School I'm sure bill
would want me to share this with you as
undergraduates we had very little reason
to be here except for the occasional art
history class but there was one notable
exception the Yale Law School Film
Society showed films here these were not
just any films they were very special it
was known as porno night yes porno night
right here at the law school so here we
are again except this time for something
worthwhile for those as I said I'm sure
he would want me to share that for those
of us who were lucky enough to have
known bill all these years he has given
each of us countless memorable moments
and stories I tried to remember the
first time I met bill but those memories
seemed to be a little foggy I'm guessing
it was probably due to the choice of
refreshments at the time but I do have
many memories that are still intact
one of my favorites was Bill 30th
birthday party in Amagansett it was
debauchery 'allah bill at its finest it
was a big group of friends and family
and he was the master of ceremonies
certainly another favorite memory of
mine was when Bill was a groomsman at
our wedding
31 years ago he became known as The
Bookman to my la friends I have a photo
see
The Bookman I met up with bill in London
about 15 years ago and he had arranged a
day of touring Follies I had no idea
what Follies were as probably many of
you don't as well but he was determined
to teach me so he booked a car and we
headed to the countryside it was classic
bill our first stop was the Rothschild
estate and we go inside of this big
beautiful old building and and I saw
what appeared to me to be a collection
of really you know they looked like rare
books and built chuckled and said these
aren't books they're furniture
he spent the day lecturing and
storytelling as everyone knows there is
no finer storyteller on the planet I've
had so many occasions to watch Bill hold
court with his his fantastic group of
book people many of whom right now and
he was always captivating in that really
fantastic bill Rhys
he could explain why a particular book
or character or location was significant
and would always leave you mesmerised
every time I would think to myself how
does he know so much during our Yale
days I knew that bill was into books
much like a nice little hobby it wasn't
until several years later that I
realized his real prowess he was in LA
in the mid 80s and it was a Saturday
morning and we dragged her selves out of
bed because he had to go see a book
dealer we get arrived at the store and
there's a man in a bowtie in a suit and
you know he looked very dapper we did
not look that well two guys in their
mid-20s and jeans and t-shirts and a
little hung over so bill began sniffing
around the shop and of course he knew
exactly where to sniff and the bow-tied
man it was becoming increasingly
uncomfortable and at this point bill
goes up to him and says hi I'm bill
Reiss and the man literally stopped and
he started like fumbling for his keys
goes your bill Reese I read your
catalogs baby started unlocking things
left right and center it was fantastic
so that's when I had a pretty good idea
that bill was not just a hobbyist to be
Bill's friend is something extraordinary
and unique he is not only
mind-bogglingly loyal but he had this
incredible capacity to appreciate and
take extraordinary pride in his friends
and their abilities always without a
hint of envy or jealousy when tony
williams became mayor of DC he beams
like a proud father as jimmy armstrong
expanded his business and became
successful it was a it was as if bill
had done it himself he spoke of Polly
Draper's successes like a brother I'm
still waiting for will gets men to be
president of Yale based on bill's
accounts truly bill who once told me
that I should have my own TV show to
feature my passion for restaurants and
electronics who else but bill would
think there's value in this just as
extraordinary is that this pride and his
friends extended to spouses and children
I heard nearly about as much about
Mariko as I did will when my wife Cathy
was on a few episodes of Beverly Hills
90210 bill was overjoyed little-known
fact
it was one of his favorite TV shows he
knew he knew every episode it was
fantastic I would say one of my favorite
memories of bill was watching him give
what I call the bill restore of his
personal library he gave this to her to
my both of my children it was built at
his absolute best he lept from shelf to
shelf almost elf like picking out just
the right materials and just delighting
in the explanation and then afterwards
he told me how impressed he was with my
kids and how smart they were it was like
a proud grandparent
I've had the good fortune to spend quite
a bit of time with Bill during the last
several years he knew of my personal
history with cancer so when he was
diagnosed we spoke quite a bit he never
complained not once during the past year
I became keenly aware of how dire his
situation was just on my knowledge of
what the treatments that he was given
were he never mentioned it
a few months ago I was here we went out
shopping for dinner and on the way he
said we need to stop with the Cancer
Center I need a blood test he said I
know you won't mind going I can't take
anyone else care so it was just business
as usual stopped in and then carried on
but I would say that one of the greatest
pleasures of knowing bill all these
years is being able to experience and
watch the evolution of Bill
much like his headquarters on Temple
Street bill has improved and evolved in
so many ways since the early days of
course in those days he was smart right
and incredibly smart but often times to
people who didn't know him he was a bit
intimidating a little rough around the
edges but over time his gentle nature
smooth those rough edges he also grew
increasingly wise he became mentor
advisor and friend to so many in so many
different capacities but I think for me
the best part of his evolution was just
how happy he was to the very very end
the last time I saw him was at their
house just a few months ago and as he
headed off to work he walked over and
gave Dorothy a kiss and he just looked
so happy I mean this was just a few
months ago so this is how I will
remember bill thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon I am Sid Lapidus
chair of the American antiquarian
Society
unlike Randy's personal remembrances
many of which were humorous mine is more
of an institutional remembrance with
only some funny parts
Dorothee condolences to you in the
extended Reese family at the service of
remembrance for our dear friend and
colleague bill Reese at Dorothy's
request
I am honored to speak on behalf of the
AAAS many of my AAAS colleagues are here
today including Ellen Dunlop a wonderful
AAAS president and a true dear friend of
Bill for many decades it is fitting that
this celebration of Bill's life is
taking place here in new haven at the by
Nicki bill was so proud of the
University and in particular its
libraries just a few years ago bill
along with ICI Schroder who I'm sure is
here who I haven't seen him director of
rare books and manuscripts here at the
binder key and also a member of our AAAS
council led my wife and me on a tour of
by Nicki and Sterling we had never been
here I was here for a lecture and Bill
insisted that I had to go on his tour
and he was right the pride bill took in
these marvelous libraries was so evident
even for me connected as I am with
Princeton and it's Forest door library
it still was pretty impressive
as you know bill was a thinker doer and
leader in so many ways especially for
what he did for the AAAS
over many decades prior to my joining in
1998 the AAAS council our governing body
I gotten to know Bill as a client I had
become a serious book collector with my
original focus primarily being pamphlets
of the American Revolutionary era and
not surprisingly to most of you was the
dealer from whom I bought the most stuff
my friend jock Herron vice chair of the
antiquarian Society was the principal
draftsman of a recent AES resolution
honoring Bill quote one of the great
book men of his or any other generation
bill Reis was unmatched in his
multi-dimensional generosity as a
scholar collector dealer educated and
philanthropist perhaps no institution
benefited as much from his counsel and
support in so many ways and for as many
years as the American antiquarian
society though became one of the
youngest members ever at 25 was elected
as a council member in 1992 and was a
longtime member of the executive
committee every aspect of the AAAS our
collections our fellowship programs are
cataloguing proficiency or strategies or
overall governance that our Treasury has
been enriched by Bill end of quote
that was the pillar of the AAAS some
years ago when I decided to resuscitate
our Executive Committee I had to start
with Bill he knew everything about
business book collecting other archival
institutions and most importantly about
people
bill knew and was known and admired by
most everyone in the American and indeed
transatlantic antiquarian book world
part of what made him so successful what
that was that he was always as was said
earlier the epitome of a gentleman and
we at the AES were so fortunate to have
Bill amongst us he was a giant a giant
we all admired him and we all loved him
in July 2014 Bill Ellen Dunlop and I had
the honor to visit the White House on
behalf of the AAAS to receive from
President and mrs. Obama the National
Humanities medal of course it was an
important and significant occasion for
the AAAS one of the most important in
our history but it was indeed an
unforgettable experience for all of us
bill just glowed this was great and he
was right no one told me but it must
have been yelled day at the White House
David Brian Davis the revealed Yale
historian of slavery in the Atlantic
world and also an AAS member also
received an neh medal that day a few
days after the White House event bill
wrote to Ellen the following note dear
Ellen I hope you are still floating on
clouds of glory
if you agree it is appropriate would you
forward this message from me to all the
AAAS staff he didn't want to go the
wreck to this day if he thought it a
proper to go through Ellen last Monday
Sid Lapidus and I were honored to
accompany Ellen to the White House to
receive the National Humanities medal on
behalf of the AAAS for its sterling
achievements as a repository and
guardian of the American past it is you
the staff of the AAAS would you and
there are many of you here today and
thank you for coming who have built and
safeguarded this institution
who should have been there as well as
one who has believed in the AES and its
mission from the day I first crossed
this threshold more than 40 years ago I
want to thank everyone make this honor a
reality and to make the AAAS what it is
the preeminent guardian of the printed
past of the American people before
closing Dorothy asked me to recognize
the Reese fellowships in the print in
the print culture of the Americas bill
created and sponsored these fellowships
at 13 institutions around the country
with a few exceptions these are research
fellowships in American book history I
hope and suspect that some of the
recipients of Bill's generosity are here
this afternoon bill will long be
remembered and celebrated as one of the
AAAS greats in an exemplary leader in so
many ways to quote jock Herron again
bill fused gravitas imagination
curiosity common sense and the good
humor needed to help the society move
with confidence into our third century
Dorothy thank you for sharing bill with
us
good afternoon I'm Alfred Harrison
I gots no bill who are membership in the
Walpole society and Bill and I were the
only dealers who were actually members
of the society so we naturally
gravitated to each other to compare
notes especially on difficult clients
and others such problems everyone else's
has outlined his virtues but I'd like to
mention one that hasn't been stressed
his wonderful sense of humor
we could see it in his Christmas cards
at Dorothy and bill sent out every year
and in many many other ways bill also
fancied himself to be an amateur poet
and so I thought it might be appropriate
to memorialize him in verse I think he'd
be amused so here goes in memoriam
William s Rees in our era when our
forefathers sins have been stressed and
their values don't pass our morality
tests though he concedes that they
preached freedom from tyranny it was
freedom for some leaving out way too
many American history has sunk to a
perilous low a subject if you care to
study or know how in the world can a
business survive or in the case of reefs
company actually thrive when his main
source of interest is on the decline as
American history rots on the vine in our
arrow and virtually all is online rare
documents and such are so easy to find
maneuver your cursor for a fast
point-and-click
there's Jefferson's letter on your
screen nice and quick who needs the
original the content is out the role of
the collector is diminished no doubt how
in the world can a business survive or
in the case of Ries company actually
thrive when the world in the field of
collecting has seen a revolution
everything's changed
and there's no easy solution
the answer to the above questions is not
far to seek the company the company's
leader has to be unique has to combine
vast knowledge with a pleasant demeanor
have a clean reputation that every deal
makes cleaner has to hunt through the
world for overlooked treasures a
collector himself who knows all its
pleasures chases with fervor Herman
Melville material the great man's lost
handkerchief and books more ethereal a
tireless supporter of libraries and such
to the AAAS by Nikki Rowley ur
contributing much the New York Times
called him a towering figure in the
world of Americana
there was nobody bigger the year 2002
was one to remember for it was then that
the Walpole society got a new member in
2002 William Reece joined the ranks
ordered a gorget and accepted with
thanks a leadership role becoming member
in charge of many great meetings where
the pleasures were large in Fort Worth
we donned shiny shoes and black ties to
what cutting horses beneath Texas skies
and werster bill used his extensive
connections to gain access to museums
and private collections and then near
the end at the top of the bay as Seven
Springs Farm we had a wonderful day
riding and pickups over pastures and
hills before a delicious dinner and bill
paid the bills
in other ways bill with the generous
contributor in this role of secretary he
became the distributor of information
that Walpole ian's needed to know the
location of meetings when and where to
go and sadly the names of the newly
departed and emails that always left us
downhearted especially the one he was
not able to send that told us his life
had come to an end and now crushed with
sadness at the loss we've been dealt
remembered that sadness only comes after
joy has been felt bill enhanced our
existence and the enhancement survives
not only in memories but in the parts of
our lives that knowing bill improved and
so our grief-stricken attitude should be
tempered at once by feelings of
gratitude thank you dear friend thank
you goodbye William race may your spirit
live on and your soul rest in peace
[Applause]
thank you all for coming and helping
celebrate Bill's life I wanted to share
a poem it's by Judah Halevi and it was
written in early 1100s I thought was
that it was particularly appropriate
it's called
tis a fearful thing it is a fearful
thing to love what death can touch a
fearful thing to love to hope to dream
to be to be and Oh to lose a thing for
fools this and a holy thing
a holy thing to love for your life has
lived in me your laugh once lifted me
your word was gift to me to remember
this brings painful joy
tis a human thing love a holy thing to
love what death has touched
I am an old woman named after my mother
my old man is another cuz it's gone old
if dreams were lightning thunder was
desire this old house would have burned
down long time ago make me opposed
just give me one thing that I can hold
on to to believe in this just when I was
a young girl I had me a cowboy he
weren't much to look at just a free
ramblin man but that was a long time and
no matter how I tried the years just
flew by like broken
[Music]
[Music]
even in puzzling and I ain't done
nothing since I woke up today l can a
person go to work in the morning and
come home in the evening and have
nothing to say
[Music]
[Music]
just give me
[Music]
just just hard way
[Music]
[Applause]
afternoon I'm Clarence Woolf bookseller
happy to be a footnote in bills
narrative I first met bill nearly fifty
years ago when he along with his parents
made a pilgrimage to Philadelphia it
come from their farm in Maryland in
order to visit settlers bookshop because
of their interest in Audubon prints at
that time settlers was Philadelphia's
premier bookshop and maples on its
proprietor was the doyen of Philadelphia
booksellers it was as newbould Smith put
it where all the swells bought their
books after the reese's had finished its
esters they made their way to the
mcmanus company our old shop was located
on Irving Street and was to say the
least
a much less traveled thoroughfare than
settlers more upscale Walnut Street
address and in those days not the
poshest of neighborhoods our building
was one of several carriage houses that
sat behind the library company and the
Historical Society of Pennsylvania and
it was the only commercial enterprise on
the block when the Reese's came in I
asked mrs. I asked mrs. Reese what they
were interested in and if they wanted my
help mrs. Reese went on to explain that
they were interested in Audubon books
and prints and continued by saying that
their son young William was interested
in Western Americana here I was face to
face with his tall gangling lad of 14
who proceeded to ask all manner of
questions about Americana and Western
Americana in particular despite having
convinced myself that the vast amount of
knowledge I had acquired in my first
year as a bookseller would be more than
sufficient to handle anything bill could
ask turned out to be wrong
and I was unable to answer the majority
of bills question I just remember being
somewhat slack-jawed at how much this
kid knew not just about that the books
but the subject matter as well now in
order to look somewhat credible and what
I can only call an act of absolute depth
desperation I produced a Western book
and proceeded to offer it to Bill
telling him that did the entirety of my
career in books I had never seen or
handled another copy his reaction
dismissive at best bill then went on to
explain why the book that I showed him
really wasn't important and continued by
telling me which books work I don't
think that the Reese's visit resulted in
a sale but I did take their names and
included them on our mailing list
several years passed before I had more
contact with Bill during his time at
Yale he joined forces with Fred White a
Texas bookseller and became partner in
frontier America Corporation which was
based in Bryan Texas the company's
primary focus was Western Americana a
subject Bill knew and loved
shortly after throwing in with Fred the
Jenkins Company of Austin acquired the
ever stout collection a greatly prized
and much publicized assemblage of
Western rarities during one of what was
to become frequent trips to Austin I met
bill
he was now 19 or 20 and was a much more
mature version of the boy that I first
met in Philadelphia at this point I
think we each felt more comfortable and
sensed in one another a kindred spirit
over the next few years while bill was
still with Fred white we had in frequent
contact but there were enough business
dealings to stay on each other's radar
in 1979 bill dissolved his partnership
with Fred divided the business and moved
to New Haven in his first catalog bill
announced that he had moved bought 409
temple Street which he was in the
process of renovating and would happily
welcome visitors upon its completion my
first visit was a memory
david holmes and i had gone on a wild
goose chase to see books in Falmouth on
Cape Cod we had been offered a
collection that was grossly
misrepresented and in addition the owner
of the books was a singularly unpleasant
man on our ride home while we were
ruminating about the day's unhappy
events I remembered that bill had moved
to New Haven these were pre cellphone
days so it required that I pull off
route 95 and called bill I got bill on
the phone told him where we were and
asked if he was in a position to receive
us by all means was the response our
mood improved and we made our way to
Temple Street which at that point was
not quite finished at the time bill was
living on the third floor in a fashion
befitting an undergraduate books were
piled on the floor boxes were scattered
about and there appeared to be no
apparent order that aside I remember
that our first transaction was a great
success and that we were all quite
pleased that was the beginning of what
was to become a near 40-year friendship
and business relationship to say that
bill hit the ground running would be an
incredible understatement in short order
he became the wunderkind of Americana
and whatever pretensions I might have
had of occupying that position quickly
dissipated brilliant gifted driven and
hardworking bill was the James Brown of
booksellers
he used all of his gifts wisely his
catalogues beginning with the very first
demonstrate his knowledge scholarship
and taste at the time of his death this
past June the Ries company had issued
its three hundred and fifty seventh
catalogue they contain and described
countless rarities are prized references
and are treasured by many in addition to
catalogues bill wrote several books some
of which have become the standard
reference his six score one hundred and
twenty books one hundred and twenty best
books on the cattle industry published
in nineteen seventy six when he was a
junior at Yale is considered the best
the best work on the subject a must for
any collector of bovine literature bill
inscribed my copy calling it and I quote
an edifying piece of cow chip literature
[Laughter]
he went on to write stamp with national
character in 19th century American color
plate books published by the growler
Club in 1999 and most recently he wrote
the revolutionary 100 the federal 100
the best of the west and lastly the
struggle for North America these have
already and will continue to be the
go-to references for their respective
fields in addition to books bill wrote
numerous articles and was a frequent
speaker as well covering topics that
included American historical
bibliography the history of the book
trade and book collecting because of his
brilliance and expertise bill had a hand
in building great collections working
with both instead of individuals and
institutions
he was extremely generous with his time
and in his willingness to help others
consequently people sought his advice
and counsel collectors and institutions
were not the only ones who saw it bill
out other booksellers did as well he had
the rare ability to have partnerships
with other booksellers and to do it
seamlessly a rare gift when one
considers the PERT the disparate
personalities of the book trade bill was
such a towering figure that it was next
to impossible for me to
grasp the idea that he was sick he first
told me about his illness when he was
driving back from his farm and stopped
to see me and brynn more when I asked
how he was his answer was he didn't know
not prone to ambiguities bill went on to
explain his diagnosis in the course of
action that was planned I was stunned
and confused how could this happen to
someone who I considered to be an
indestructible force of nature for the
next five years bill carried on as usual
often returning to work after a
chemotherapy session as in all things he
was grace under fire and carried on as
if nothing was wrong I visited bill in
the hospital about a week before he died
and then saw him at the farm the
following Saturday bill was as sharp as
ever even correcting Don healed as to
wear a print had been acquired Bill's
passing is a loss that is shared by many
his family friends colleagues and the
institutions and collectors that he
served the rhythm of my life has been
greatly altered and I know the same can
be said of others his friendship his
philanthropy this keen intellect and
scholarship will be missed terribly I
think it is safe to say that bill has
earned a place in that rarefied pantheon
a Bookman that includes names like
Huntington Rosenwald Rosen back every
stat and Streeter our book world is a
small one but Bill's presence made it so
much larger and in the end I can only
say how privileged I was to have known
bill and you have counted him among my
dearest of friends
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon I'm George Myles curator
of the Yale collection of Western
Americana - Dorothy
Barbara Reverend Jackson Andrew - will
Mariko Zooey Emily and Todd - Terry and
Laura - Leslie - all the past and
current employees of risco who are here
today please know that all of us in the
Yale library all of us here today are
united with you in the grief and
mourning that we all feel at Bill's
passing and also in the love we all feel
for him and for you
Bill's death was a wound a searing pain
that brought tears to my eyes and left
me speechless for weeks afterwards as
the months have gone by that raw wound
has begun to heal and I begun to recover
my emotional composure my soul still
aches when I think of Bill I expect that
it always will but I've come to
appreciate that ache for a while it is
painful it also triggers memories
memories of time with bill that remind
you how fortunate I am to be able to say
I was a friend of Bill Reese I hope you
won't consider me self-indulgent if
instead of providing a dry accurate
summary of Bill's many accomplishments
and of his extraordinary service to the
by Nicki library and to Yale University
in general that I share a few stories
personal narratives - still Bill's
phrase drawn from memory you'll have to
decide whether the narrator is reliable
or not the earliest oldest memory I can
summon a bill is 43 euro 43 years old
almost to the day or to the week it's
late September or early October of 1975
though I can't recall the specific week
I know it was a Wednesday afternoon
because we were sitting in Howard
Lamar's graduate seminar in the history
and culture of the trans-mississippi
West which met every Wednesday that fall
in by Nicky library's room 28 I was in
my second year of graduate school one of
nearly a dozen graduate students in the
seminar bill was a junior history major
the only undergraduate in the class and
I confess then through the first few
weeks of class I don't I can't recall
taking notice of him but each class
session would begin with student reports
intended to spark and shape class
discussion typically us being graduate
students they focused on interpretive
differences among scholarly experts but
at this class the third or fourth of the
semester bill had taken responsibility
for starting our conversation about
Lewis and Clark an American exploration
of the trans-mississippi West and there
was bill and what I came to recognize as
his unofficial uniform running shoes
khakis and an open collar shirt he was
sitting beneath William Clark's
magnificent five foot by three foot
manuscript map of the West which hung
framed on the classroom wall and over
the first 30 minutes of class bill not
only discussed what the exhibition
accomplished but also the bibliographic
history of its publications he
introduced a cast of 19th and early 20th
century editors printers and publishers
unknown to me at the time from Nicholas
Biddle and Paul Allen to Eliot cooze
Francis Harper and Reuben Reuben
Goldthwait's he traced the history not
only of the expedition but the history
of how the story of the expedition
reached the American public it was a
bibliographic tour de force that
anticipated all the things we now think
of as history of the book
it was one that left me and from the
looks I saw on the faces of most of my
graduate colleagues channeling Butch
Cassidy talking to Sundance about the
Pinkertons who is this guy
at that point Howard knew what we didn't
know that the previous winner bill had
identified a 16th century map of Mexico
City at a furniture auction in New York
had purchased it at a steal and sold it
to by Nicky for the cost of his
remaining undergraduate tuition by mid
spring of that year he had while
completing a sophomore year at Yale he
had purchased a private collection of
more than 4,000 volumes of rare
Americana partnered with Fred White jr.
to found the rare book firm frontier
americano and would spend that next
summer cataloging and selling books in
College Station Texas a few months after
his presentation and Howard seminar bill
published his first bibliography to
which Clarence referred earlier six
score 120 best books on the range cattle
industry I had been introduced to genius
nearly six years later in the spring of
1981 I was fortunate to be offered the
opportunity to succeed
Archie Hannah as curator of the Yale
collection of Western Americana Rudi
Rodgers the university librarian
appointed bill to be advisor to the
collection it was the best bon voyage
present that any wet-behind-the-ears
academic novice curator could ever
receive bill never regarded his
appointment as conferring authority or
power to make decisions about the
collection he treated it as a commitment
to be available to answer any and all
questions that this naive young academic
might have about the antiquarian book
trade and to gently guide my development
meeting antiquarian book sellers was the
first priority early in my tenure I
recall bill hiring a
car to take us to Montclair New Jersey
to get with the legendary book stellar
Lindley ever stat I was a little puzzled
that we needed a Town Car to do this but
bill knew that the best way to get
Lindley to talk freely about Americana
and the book trade was to take him to
lunch at his favorite Chinese restaurant
and literally never drove and Bill
observed that we had zero chance of
persuading him to get into either of the
beat-up used cars that we were driving
at that point lesson one know your
audience over the following months bill
took me to meet Warren Hal and bill
readin in California sent me off to
Chicago to meet Ken Devin's all to
Boston to see George good speed and Sam
Morril but Bill didn't just introduce me
to the old guard many of whom were about
to retire from the trade he went out of
his way to make sure that I got to know
the emerging figures in the field his
principal confess his principal
competitors and the Americana trade
Michael Ginsberg Ginsberg Michael
Houston Clarence Woolf Bailey Bishop
John Jenkins
Dorothy Sloan Peter Crawley Walter Rubin
many others this is a pattern that
continued for decades as bill went out
of his way to make sure that I met
up-and-coming booksellers Dave
chevchenko Venson Warren bear Don healed
and on and on it went indeed I can't
recall a book fair at which bill didn't
encourage me to visit one or another
dealer they have interesting things he
would say my visits to 4:09 Temple
Street were an advanced seminar in
primary sources for innovative
scholarship in American history and
culture bill allowed me to occupy him
for hours of time to chat not only about
the books and manuscripts in the latest
recent catalogue but available in the
trade at large he helped me to
appreciate that academically trained
scholars too frequently focused on the
same canonical sources overlooking
opportunities to delve into
neglected sources we bonded over a
mutual fascination with Native American
languages illustrated travels and 19th
century city directories bill was
especially helpful in guiding me through
the ins and outs of auctions he would
gently dissuade me from placing overly
aggressive bids on books or pamphlets
that he knew would reappear in the trade
shortly but other times he warned me
that my proposed bid wouldn't get the
job done in June 1998 Pacific book
auctions a kpba galleries listed for
auction a copy of GRF Arden's views of
San Francisco the first photographic
view book of any North American city
only a half dozen copies the album could
be located and none had been offered at
auction in a hundred years it was a book
that fit by Nikki's interests it was a
book that excited bill as well as me and
over a course of a couple of weeks we
decided that since it was unlikely we'd
ever have another opportunity to obtain
a copy we should bid extremely
aggressively with Bill's encouragement
and the support of by Nicky's director
Ralph Franklin we set a maximum bid at
three times the high estimate 150,000
dollar hammer we wanted a lot at that
bid the House Commission would raise the
total cost to nearly a hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars it was by
far the highest bid I'd ever proposed at
the sale on June 25th we ended up being
the under bidder to Frankl gallery of
San Francisco I resigned myself that we
would never acquire a foreign album for
Yale and began to think about other
acquisitions less than two weeks later I
picked up the phone in my office to hear
Bill at the other end say how would you
like to get a fartin with more pictures
for less money than you were willing to
pay at auction he had learned about an
album that was in the hands of an East
Bay family since November 2nd 1858 when
James defray Murray had
described it as a gift to his wife the
firmer he had added additional
photographs of his house and
neighborhood to the album and that album
it stayed in family hands for a hundred
and fifty years the publicity generated
by the sale had led the family to reach
out to bill who leveraged the auction
house premiums to set a price that cost
us less and paid the family more than
either of us would have realized at
auction I think he took a special
pleasure at being able to do that over
the next few years the Frankel gallery
broke the copy they purchased selling
the photos individually
I suspect bill knew he could have done
the same thing but instead he wanted to
see that volume at the by Nicki later
today if you want you can see that copy
acquired with the help of bill's magic
touch in a small exhibition back at the
library in 1987 Terrie Bellinger asked
Bill to teach a class on Western
Americana at the rare book school then
operating at Columbia University bill
generously told Terry he would do so
only if I was appointed co-instructor we
eventually taught four times at Columbia
and once at the University of Virginia
I've never told Terry but I was always
afraid that he would realize that I was
learning as much as I was teaching in
all of those classes and demand that I
pay for the privilege was also in
teaching those classes that I came to
appreciate that the impish qualities of
the undergraduate bill Reese survived
into his more mature years those of you
who have taught her attended classes at
rare-book school know that Terry and his
successor Michael Suarez do a fabulous
job of arranging for evening lectures by
scholars collectors librarians and
dealers faculty are expected to attend
but that hot summer week in Virginia a
friend of bills
approached us and said that he could
take us to Monticello that night we
decided to play hooky and commune with
the ghosts of Thomas Jefferson and Sally
Hemings rather than 1/10 at evenings
lecture
Terry forgave bill who
went on to deliver several notable
stellar rbs lectures I think I may still
be in the doghouse I can go on and tell
many more stories that reveal bills
erudition his curiosity his
entrepreneurial skills his commitment to
Yale but I'd like to close with two
memories one from my earliest days of
time with Bill and one from this past
winter which remind me that Bill was as
passionate about people as he was about
books and suggests to me that the Ries
company was as much about making friends
as it was about making money
409 temple Street was always more than a
site of business for Bill he used to
host visiting scholars on that
third-floor bedroom and I discovered
early on that the best time to visit 409
Temple Street was lunchtime when Laura
Halliday would be serving her signature
chili seasoned by Archie Hannah's
homegrown jalapeno peppers over the
years takeout replaced home-cooked meals
but Bill's reputation for hospitality
never faded whether it was hosting
dinner for the old book table or
inviting rare book school students and
instructors to drinks at Temple Street
bill loved a good party
last February at the California
antiquarian book fair my wife and I were
fortunate to join bill Dorothy and more
than two dozen of Bill's colleagues in
the trade for a dinner
he threw after the Book Fair closed for
the night Bill's enormous smile his
booming voice conveyed the pleasure he
took in sharing the time and the space
with friends that night it seemed as if
for Bill the Book Fairs principle
purpose was to get together with friends
books were important to bill but the
friendships they created were his
lifeblood thank you for allowing me to
recall bill
to summon him in in memory this
afternoon and I think I'm probably
channeling Reverend Jackson because I
know that all of you have stories of
your time with Bill when you see me
today or in the future I hope you'll
share them with me they'll make me ache
but they'll also remind me of the great
blessing I enjoyed and meeting and
knowing and working with an
extraordinary man
[Applause]
it feels like a series of multiple
hospital passes to have to follow these
speakers I'll do my best
I'm Edie mags I'm a bookseller from
London England bill was one of us as a
bookseller and he was the best of us
he was the least cynical of people and
Oscar Wilde's cynic is one who knows the
price of everything and the value of
nothing bill knew both the value and the
price of everything commercial and
cultural appreciation were in perfect
equilibrium with bill and this is said
this in a trade where there were many of
us who never read a book and there were
many of us who couldn't sell a ten
dollar bill for five bill relish being
in the tradition of the Rosen backs the
Robinsons eating house and Howells a
burst at the list could be longer and
this lab of the micro history of the
book trade coexisted with his huge
historical knowledge that we've heard of
before and didn't he loved showing it
off I remember him listing from memory
all the British monarchs from Caractacus
I think a recital in that deep voice
they projected so well across the
restaurant or the Book Fair
you could often find bill in a book fed
by the voice alone it was like a bitten
booming across the fin that vegetation
was characteristically part of a
performance over dinner where sometimes
there would be a little bit of the old
general
reenacting his great campaigns and
during these performances I always
expected the table ornaments to be
brought into play as props the
Peppermill here would be Frank Streeter
the wine-bottle Thomas and advancing
behind the breadbasket came that copy of
Champlain's yr G's with other people who
said memory made me many memories of
Bill who evolved around the dinner table
where he demonstrated his a petitioners
discriminating delight and his enjoyment
of company although I learnt much from
Bill about books about kindness about
history none of them were as valuable as
the key life lesson always ask that try
of the grabba in i got no bill thanks to
in the late 1970s my father John wisely
sent me to do an informal apprenticeship
not with somewhere respectable like
Howell or cows but with the maverick
Johnny Jenkins in Austin Texas where
where Terry Holliday was one of the poor
employees when the Paul Jenkins
employees allocated to try and do
something with this odd thing which who
had turned up and he saw me through some
memorable rites of passage in an
intoxicating summer when I spent the
days trying to catalog Western Americana
and the Knights enjoying the life of a
college town life moved on and a few
years later I was being kept occupied
doing Sisyphean tasks in the basement at
max he really was in bliss the mag's
basement when I was caught up the shop
where some people were asking after me
it was Terry Holliday bringing bill with
him on an early buying trip to London
and I remember my first sight of Bill
tall a trifle underfed and big-eared
this wasn't just a joyous reunion with
Terry but the beginning of a new union
between the William Reece company and
Marx Brothers limited in London mags
may not have been quite a sleeping giant
but he was certainly having a bit of a
nap at the time we had a legendary back
stock particularly of travel books but
much of it was in chaos and although we
were doing very well in some areas in
other areas we were really very very
dozy and the arrival of a trustworthy
partner in the states to collaborate
with was an absolute godsend the bill
was already this is the early 80s miles
ahead of the rest of the trade in terms
of energy integrity and ambition firms
like us with legacy stock are often
paranoid about prices if you haven't
bought the book you haven't got the cost
the to act as a sort of a base and to
deal with us to do business with people
like us you have to be very patient very
informed and very gentle and bill with
all these things I know that bill took
pride in cracking
the mag's basement but we also took
great pride in being tracked by bill
well it was the intensity of bills bill
helped infuse me personally about this
trade but I grew up surrounded by this
funny old business this funny old
bookshop and the books and I couldn't
help but take it for granted as I tried
puzzling me to work out what it all
meant and the intensity of billows
belief in the importance of this line of
work really did inspire me he he helped
make sense of it for me he's delight in
every aspect of it was infectious
whether it was wrangling difficult
collectors or conspiring with the nicer
ones whether it was sabotaging the plans
of enemies or celebrating the successes
of allies enjoying the grim pleasures of
the roadtrip that bizarre lightless
intensity of Book Fairs
and the profound pleasures of
discovering pearls in mittens Bill's
influence continues I drove here with
his old friend Michael Zeidman one of
the champion cloaca cleaners of the
world Michael Michael pulled this out of
his local bookshop in upstate New York
yesterday and said he claimed not to
have even opened it and he said this
might be interesting to you it turns out
to be a Dave Richards where's Dave
Dave's not here good we can get away
with this this is the editors set of a
seemingly very rare juvenile periodical
called wee willie winkie 1891 - 1892
with an interesting and apparently
completely obscure contribution from
Rudyard Kipling printed in facsimile
they'd seen wildly appropriate that this
should have been the consequence of the
event today I wouldn't have it wouldn't
all have happened bill would have been
tickled pink and I don't believe that
yeah I'll have a copy I don't think it's
in Dave's bibliography Michael and I had
a discussion this morning about what to
do with it I said a bill may be the
appropriate thing would be to give it to
Yale in in Bill's memory Michael was
he went pale give it give it
Samet said Michael so that's one of the
spirits of Bill but I don't think this
will pay many weeks tuition but he might
contribute towards the airfare I was
very proud when Bill spoke at the
reopening of our bookshop a year and a
half ago but bill also saw me at my very
worst on a couple of occasions when his
kindness was exemplary this isn't the
place for confessionals so I'll hold a
couple of stories within and I'll stick
for the story of me at my second worst
or maybe third worst you're worried
aren't you the some years ago we planned
a day out at the seaside in England to
go and eat crabs at the legendary
company shed in West Mersey I was to
collect bill and Dorothy from their Park
Street apartment in the morning and I
left a message
the day before confirming the time that
I was going to pick them up that could I
really have specified two hours early
maybe it was three hours maybe it was
four anyway the message meant that they
rosa two really unwholesome the early
hour to spend a long time waiting for me
and I'll never forget the kind steel in
bills voice when I attempted to deny my
error bill said I have the recording
bill really was the perfect dealer and a
kind and loyal friend the most important
thing about him is hard to express
almost everyone here who knows him sort
of knows this instinctively but it's
important for me to try and say it and I
can only say it with a certain
coarseness in my language for which I
apologize in advance one of the
tragedies of the English language is
that there isn't a positive word to
express the to express the sentiment
that bill wasn't an [ __ ]
the reason I said is the reason I said
is that he had every justification to be
one but he was he was successful he was
handsome he was eloquent he was popular
and he wasn't [ __ ] I think Yiddish
has a word for it meant but we'll have
to rely on the relatively weak bill was
a very good man we'll miss him look I
haven't really got an ending for this
but when you finished you end and
without unless it's two more kiss I'd
say that when we've been too many people
dying these days and we all gathered to
say how much we loved them but let's
remember to love the people that we can
while they're still living as well as
remembering when they're dead but thank
you very much for inviting me to be part
of this is for Bill this institution
this institution was begun by Isaiah
Thomas an American printer he was one of
the primary Patriot printers it came to
Westar during the American Revolution
when his political beliefs caused him to
flee Boston when he founded the American
antiquarian Society his goal was to
preserve the printed heritage of the
American colonies that had become the
United States he knew what the printed
word could do he understood that words
were what had built America as much as
anything the object can set for 200
years and nobody can know why it's
needed no scholar can put it in context
and tell that moment when that piece of
paper tells a story provides a
connection you never know when some
scholar is going to need that single
connective piece that's going to make
their whole story fall into place
that's why places like this exist and
that's why places like this are precious
[Music]
[Music]
may God bless you and keep you away
maiya wishes are come true me always do
for others yet others do for you
Mia build a ladder to the Stars and
climb on every rung misty
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay